[Music]  these are a little bit darker so that's  the Kopi Luwak and then this is what the  one we just drank so these two are the  same how can you tell how can you know  I'm just drink that much coffee  are you serious very busy Natalie I  drink a lot just is the distance this  test right here which one is the Oh  nama which one is this that would be the  copula okay King - how much I cannot  tell if you guess right man I'm gonna  give you a hundred  [Music]  [Applause]  between both of these are the ones who  just tried the one you just pulled out  was the one you described and this one  then this one is one we're about to try  oh so they look just exactly how am i  doing  [Music]